[Musica]
Io credo di aver sempre voluto fare il
musicista
mio padre suonava il pianoforte e mi
raccontano che quando lui suonava a casa
io gatto Lando gattonando ancora prima
di camminare andavo sotto il pianoforte
e restavo a sentirlo magari per un'ora
un'ora e mezzo
Quindi per me in qualche modo la scelta
della musica la scelta di fare musicista
è stata naturale ma non la scelta
dell'Opera non il rapporto con il
melodramma a casa non si sentiva mio
padre non lo amava e quindi ho dovuto
conquistare il rapporto l'amore verso
l'opera la dovuta conquistare per conto
mio pian piano lentamente
la scoperta dell'Opera E che cosa ho
scoperto Beh Prima di tutto ho scoperto
che L'opera è il grande spettacolo
multimediale è un po' Il cinema dei
secoli passati il grande spettacolo
Popolare a cui tutti partecipano in un
grande spazio
ed è uno spettacolo che appunto è
multimediale dal vivo naturalmente ed è
composto Quindi da una storia c'è una
narrazione cioè la recitazione ci sono
le scene le luci i costumi il ballo
molto spesso ma soprattutto c'è la
musica
l'opera ha una particolarità L'opera è
un genere in cui è la musica a
raccontare la vicenda la musica
articolare il dramma ma questo come è
possibile come può la musica raccontare
può farlo meglio delle parole
bene i grandi compositori d'opera
scoprono una cosa che è un po' Il
segreto dell'Opera ed è un segreto
ancora oggi valido nella musica che
sentiamo tutti i giorni
scoprono
che la musica può dire cose che le
parole non riescono a dire
quali sono queste cose Beh
essenzialmente le nostre emozioni i
nostri sentimenti la nostra interiorità
la musica riesce a rendere subito
evidente un sentimento
e lo fa attraverso il canto dell'Opera
attraverso la voce quindi letteralmente
da voce alla nostra interiorità è un
linguaggio come ha detto qualcuno delle
emozioni Qualcuno ha definito la musica
come il linguaggio delle emozioni e
allora Dato che qui c'è un pianoforte
volevo
affrontare qualche famosissimo pezzo
d'opera per vedere che cos'è questo
linguaggio delle emozioni e in che modo
riesce effettivamente a dare vita al
dare forma dare espressione ai
sentimenti
Volevo farvi sentire un pezzo di una
delle opere più famose più eseguite in
assoluto che La traviata di Giuseppe
Verdi
metà dell'Ottocento 1853 più esattamente
La Traviata la protagonista Violetta è
una donna Traviata è una prostituta una
cortigiana nel primo atto di quest'opera
si svolge una festa da ballo in casa di
Violetta Partecipa a un giovane Alfredo
che a un certo punto le rivela di essere
innamorato di lei da più di un anno e
durante questo duetto molto intenso
Alfredo a un certo punto canta questa
famosa melodia le parole dicono di
quell'amor quella morte è palpito
dell'universo intero
misterioso e Altero Croce e delizia al
Cora Croce e delizia È un'espressione
che naturalmente poi è entrata nel
linguaggio comune e la melodia con la
quale Alfredo canta questa dichiarazione
d'amore melodia famosissima è
tensione misterioso
melodia famosissima peraltro poi Alfredo
esce tutti escono la festa finisce
Violetta resta da sola e comincia a
rimuginare su queste parole su questa
dichiarazione del tutto inaspettata che
ha ricevuto e dice nessuno mi è mai
riuscito effettivamente a coinvolgermi
affettivamente ad accendermi perché
allora queste parole risuonano così
forte dentro di me e comincia a cantare
questa famosissima aria questo brano
solistico e all'inizio un po' esitante
si chiede se sia proprio lui Cioè ha
forse lui che l'anima che
potrebbe riuscire ad accendere l'anima e
comincia appunto con questo gesto un po'
esitante
poi l'anima
musica un po' Mesta la sentite stai
interrogandosi sta cercando una
motivazione sta cercando di capire la
musica Sale sale finché Violetta canta
esattamente le parole e la musica della
grande dichiarazione d'amore che Alfredo
le aveva fatto qualche minuto prima
riascoltiamo la stessa melodia la prima
volta L'abbiamo sentita ed era una
dichiarazione d'amore la seconda volta è
il riflesso nell'anima di Violetta di
questa dichiarazione d'amore e Violetta
canta si sfoga questa grande apertura
melodica poi si ferma Si riscuote dice
che sto facendo queste sono follie sono
follie è un delirio vano io sono una
povera donna sola abbandonata in questo
popoloso deserto che chiamano Parigi la
tentacolare metropoli ottocentesca e
quindi reagisce dice che fare del giro
che devo fare gioire di volumità nei
vortici perire e comincia la seconda
parte dell'aria che tecnicamente si
chiama la caballetta che è completamente
diversa e mosse agitata così frenetica
Addirittura il testo dice sempre libera
degio folleggiare di gioia in gioia
[Musica]
sentite la musica con te più agitata
quasi fare inedite in realtà Violetta è
quasi isterica in questo tentativo di
resistere all'amore addirittura canta
si spinge verso queste note acutissime
sta cantando proprio sopra le righe
sopra le righe È un termine che viene
dalla musica vuol dire quando le note
acutissime superano di molto il Rigo più
a più alto del pentagramma cantare sopra
le righe un altro esempio di linguaggio
musicale che è entrato nell'uso corretto
e proprio in questo momento parossistico
isterico in cui lei sta proprio cercando
di convincersi che no L'amore non le
interessa sentiamo Alfredo che da fuori
fuori dalla finestra canta
e questo è
la stessa melodia naturalmente che
abbiamo già sentito la cantata Alfredo
per dichiarare il suo amore verso
Violetta La cantata Violetta nel momento
in cui stava chiedendo si sia Alfredo
fosse l'uomo per lei la canta nuovamente
Alfredo da fuori ed è il simbolo
musicale dell'amore che penetra sempre
più a fondo nell'animo di Violetta ora
da questa rapidissima descrizione Noi
capiamo Intanto il modo in cui la musica
da voce al sentimento
pensate i sentimenti di Violetta
brillante cortigiana che dà una festa da
ballo riceve una dichiarazione d'amore
esita titubante ricorda questa
dichiarazione decide di reagire Ma
questa melodia che rappresenta l'amore
naturalmente che arriva da fuori penetra
sempre più a fondo nel suo animo
all'inizio del secondo atto Alfredo
Violetto saranno insieme la musica è
un'arte che si svolge nel tempo ha
bisogno della ripetizione Ma la
ripetizione come vedete della stessa
melodia che però cambia significato
drammatico e in qualche modo ci mostra
quindi l'evoluzione di un personaggio il
modo in cui l'interiorità di Violetta si
trasforma progressivamente lo stato
d'animo cambia Questo è un tipo di
processo psicologico che naturalmente un
grande scrittore potrebbe essere
potrebbe in qualche modo rendere in
maniera altrettanto efficace in un
romanzo ma in un romanzo Il Grande
scrittore dovrebbe scrivere delle pagine
di introspezione psicologica
profondissima sarebbero le pagine più
difficili più dense più complesse da
leggere del romanzo invece dell'opera La
lunghezza della melodia La forza della
musica il dar voce alle interiorità
ottiene un risultato che è
immediatamente comprensibile e
coinvolgente per migliaia di spettatori
Questo è il miracolo dell'Opera
Ma la vera può fare di più il linguaggio
operistico può darci delle altre
emozioni per esempio può in qualche modo
rendere evidente Palese l'interazione
fra più personaggi per esempio fra due
personaggi che discutono fra loro volevo
parlarvi di una famosa scena di
seduzione
di una altra grandissima opera scritta
prima alla fine del Settecento da Mozart
il Don Giovanni il primo atto del Don
Giovanni c'è un grande famosissimo
duetto fra il cavaliere licenzioso che è
Don Giovanni una contadina che stava
sposandosi Don Giovanni irrompe
rapidissimo è sempre fulmineo caccia il
marito e dice azerlina che lavora a
sposare e comincia questo duetto
sbalorditivo in cui il cavaliere è
assolutamente come dire in positivo
assolutamente vuole conquistare questa
fanciulla la ragazza all'inizio è un po'
ritrosa in realtà non è che faccio una
resistenza proprio strenua eh diciamo la
verità in tre strofe cede però
sostanzialmente lui
in tre strofe Lui canta l'acido rende la
mano Lami Direi di sì vuole portarla in
un suo casottino vedi non è lontano
partiamo dal mio di qui quindi là Ci
darei la mano là mi direi di sentite il
gesto proprio imperioso
altra melodia famosissima Naturalmente
per Lena risponde
è interessante perché risponde con la
stessa melodia ma mentre Don Giovanni
comincia come diciamo noi musicisti sul
tempo Forte
zerlina canta vorrei e non vorrei mi
trema un poco il core felice e versarei
ma può burlarmi ancora non si fida
esattamente di questo Cavaliere Infatti
canta
c'è una nota in più è più incerta e più
Indecisa la linea di zerlina
ora in un duetto in questo periodo la
prima strofa è cantata da un personaggio
qui è Don Giovanni la seconda dall'altro
personaggio poi due cominciano a
discutere a parlare fra loro a dialogare
un verso per uno e qui interessantissimo
il libretto cambia schema metrico Prima
abbiamo l'acida nella mano la mi dirai
di sì vedi non è lontano partiamo per
mio da qui vorrei non vorrei mi trema un
poco il core sono rime alternate
tecnicamente Ma la terza strofa che è la
strofa in cui la seduzione giunge a buon
fine terrina cede la strofa Il testo
dice vieni mio bel diletto e zelina
Ancora pensa al marito dice mi sa pietà
Masetto io cangerò tua sorte dice Don
Giovanni e lei presto Non son più forte
e le rime come sono vieni mio bel
diletto Mi Fa pietà Masetto io cangerò
tua sorte presto Non son più forte
queste rime si chiamano tecnicamente
baciate
capite Nell'istante in cui la seduzione
sta prendendo corpo
e quindi Don Giovanni canta
e berlina
[Musica]
e in che modo attraverso la tecnica
musicale il compositore pian piano rende
fisicamente presente la scena di
seduzione poi due ricominciano a cantare
il testo dall'inizio ma alternano i
versi e soprattutto pian piano Mozart
avvicina le due parti vocali ed è
letteralmente l'immagine l'immagine
fisica della dell'abbraccio La Piovra
Don Giovanni che con i tentacoli avvolge
questa ragazza nelle sue spire Giovanni
è un personaggio inquietante questo
Libertino clamoroso che ha avuto
migliaia di donne e la musica lo rende
proprio evidente se voi poteste vedere
il manoscritto di Mozart Nell'istante in
cui le voci sono più ravvicinate
cantano proprio alternandosi a
rapidissima distanza brevissima distanza
in questo istante nel manoscritto Mozart
scrive le gambe delle note che si
avvicinano fra loro è proprio l'immagine
fisica dell'abbraccio e poi c'è l'ultima
strofa la quarta strofa in cui i due
personaggi cantano insieme lo stesso
testo il testo dice andiamo Andiamo bene
a ristorarle bene di un innocente amor
nostro pezzo celeberrimo naturalmente
notate un elemento tecnico qui Mozart
cambia ritmo prima era in due 1 2 1 2
Qui invece è in tre Un due tre Un due
tre
si sente la differenza sapete perché
perché
zerlina era Entrata in scena per la
prima volta nell'opera su questo ritmo
poco prima Nell'istante in cui si stava
celebrando il matrimonio con il povero
Masetto che poi viene immediatamente
cacciato da Don Giovanni zerlina canta
giovinetti che fate all'amore che fate
all'amore Un due tre Un due tre e lo
stesso identico ritmo sul quale finisce
il duetto nell'istante preciso in cui la
seduzione è compiuta e questo significa
una cosa profonda significa che Mozart
in questo caso fa dialogare fra loro il
linguaggio musicale del Cavaliere
attraverso il nobile ritmo di danza e il
linguaggio Popolare i personaggi
popolari contadini in particolare nelle
opere di Mozart molto spesso cantano su
questo ritmo Un due tre Un due tre Un
due tre quindi nell'opera di Mozart c'è
attraverso la musica una dialettica tra
le classi sociali siamo nel
1787 due anni prima della Rivoluzione
francese questo significa evidentemente
che beh l'opera non non parla solo dei
nostri sentimenti non parla soltanto
delle emozioni l'opera parla anche del
mondo parla anche di ciò che sta
succedendo intorno a noi Parla magari
anche del modo di riuscire a risolvere i
problemi della società nella precedente
opera di Mozart due plebei Susanna e
sigaro riuscivano ad avere ragione del
conte di un nobile nel 1786
l'opera parla di noi parla della nostra
interiorità Ma parla anche del mondo che
abbiamo intorno e se ci pensate in
realtà il
le canzoni che noi sentiamo oggi di che
cosa parlano parlano d'amore parlano di
rabbia di dolore di tristezza di gioia
un'area d'opera di che cosa parla
d'amore di rabbia di
gioia di dolore
la stessa scoperta dei grandi
compositori d'opera continua a essere
valida ancora oggi nella musica che
sentiamo tutti i giorni detto in altro
modo Abbiamo sempre bisogno dell'Opera
Grazie
[Applauso]